[Musique]
avoir 20 ans et envisager l'avenir est
souvent
actuellement pour les jaunes va fait
d'épreuves toujours prêt ça n'est pas
toujours très très très clair
pour tout bagage en a 20 ans on a
l'expérience des parents se fout du
tiers comme du quart
on prend le bonheur toujours en retard
quand on aime c'est pour toute la vie
cette fille qui tour l'espace d'un cri
du permanente d'ingouchie une épaule
home est on imagine
qu'est ce que ça représente pour toi
d'avoir 20 ans
le clip
un clip beaucoup et c'est facile d'être
libre ah non pourquoi il ya toujours des
parents derrière les parents empêche
d'être les vous pas exactement mais ils
font rien pour l'histoire c'est le début
des difficultés de la vie
la compréhension six amis nixon
il ya deux sortes seul le chien du
sérieux et des jeunes pas sérieux
seulement moi je trouve ce n'est pas
beaucoup
allen c'est beaucoup la famille et pis
le couvrir le mans qui a beaucoup plus
d'opposition entre les adultes et jeunes
que de compréhension et par conséquent
les mélanges la révolution est toujours
en opposition par rapport aux adultes et
par conséquent il faut pas le dire qui
est fatigué
pour tout bagage en sa gueule qui pose
des fois quand on est seul c'est ce que
la belle est la voie du temps ça fait
parfois de boucan
pas moyen de tourner le bouton de cette
radio on est marron
on passe alex ammann min et quand on
pleure on rit pas
la jeunesse estime peut-être qu'elle est
brimé mais je pense que l fait de
mauvaises routes par moment elle va plus
vite que l'évolution du siècle vous
regrettez vos vingt ans à londres avec
une leukemans en le maintenant
oh oui oh oui on arrive on approche à
rien en quelques travail et jantes et
d'entérite gowlings écoulables y voilà
[Musique]